26 juillet 2021 le président de la
république emmanuel macron continue sa
visite présidentielle en polynésie
française visite débutée samedi dernier
et vous le voyez sur ces images il a été
accueilli il ya quelques heures aux îles
marquises
ce voyage devrait être pour le chef de
l'état à l'occasion de s'exprimer
publiquement entre autres sur le sujet
épineux du nucléaire une intervention
est d'ailleurs attendu demain avant son
départ de la polynésie
on va rappeler un que pendant trente ans
entre 1966 et 1996 193 essais nucléaires
ont été menées en polynésie française
par la france des essais atmosphériques
d'abord entre 1966 et 1974
et puis des essais souterrains ont lieu
entre 1975 et 1996 ces essais n'ont pas
été sans conséquences sur la santé des
populations locales
pour nous éclairer sur ce sujet nous
avons le plaisir d'avoir avec nous un
expert sébastien philippe bonjour
sébastien philippe merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté notre invitation en
direct aujourd'hui sur figaro live vous
êtes ingénieur docteur et enseignant
chercheur à l'université de princeton
aux états unis et vous êtes spécialiste
du nucléaire militaire
vous avez fait paraître il ya quelques
semaines l'ouvragé toxiques paru aux
éditions puf pour être précise il s'agit
d'une enquête de deux années mené avec
le journaliste thomas status et le média
d'investigation disclose qui vise à
comprendre l'impact des essais
nucléaires français sur les populations
polynésiennes et d'abord j'aimerais vous
demander pourquoi vous avez été
intéressé qu est-ce qui vous avez
qu'est-ce qui vous intéressait dans ce
sujet pourquoi vous vous y êtes
intéressé mais alors
merci en tout cas de cette invitation
donc ça pour moi le projet il a commencé
il ya deux ans en fait donc ça fait plus
de dix ans que je travaille sur les
questions de nucléaire militaire mais il
ya deux ans on m'a approché justement
avec une manne de documents français
déclassifiés qui donne le détail un
petit peu d'aidé
des mesures des retombées nucléaires on
va dire des retombées radioactives des
essais français dans le pacifique
ces documents qu'ils sont vraiment
uniques j'avais jamais pu voir avant
bien sûr et c'est en parcourant cette
manne des documents que me suis rendu
compte que on pouvait raconter une
histoire une histoire qui avait pas
encore été dit sur l'impact de ces
éléments sur sur ce côté qui n'a pas été
a révélé avant avant 2013 d'abord et
puis par votre l'intermédiaire de votre
enquête depuis vous avez donc étudié
deux mille pages de documents
déclassifiés par le ministère de la
défense en 2013 et pour reprendre la
formule de thomas status avec lequel
vous avez écrit cette enquête vous avez
joué le rôle de passeur de connaissances
pour comprendre et décrypter ces deux
mille pages d' archives déclassifiées et
faire que nous bien le public on n'y
comprennent quelque chose alors dans les
grandes lignes qu'avez vous découvert
qui a justifié que cette enquête soit
publiée aujourd'hui dans les grandes
lignes on sait donc par l'analyse des
documents donc qui sont extrêmement
techniques
on a eu pour la première fois les
données sources des mesures de l'époque
faut savoir qu'à l'époque la france
disait qui avait pas d'impact pour les
populations locales voire très peu et là
on se rend compte et on effaçait deux
documents qui vont décrire la
contamination des denrées alimentaires
des sources d'eau potable pour les
habitants des îles voisines et ce genre
de choses quelque chose qui a jamais été
vraiment exploité par les chercheurs
la manière indépendante comme on
l'expliqué d'ailleurs ça que ça n'a
jamais été vraiment susciter plus
d'intérêt que ça parce que finalement
depuis 2013
c'est plutôt vous aujourd'hui depuis
mars 2021 qui est à l'origine d'une
divulgation un peu plus prégnante de ces
éléments là alors ce qu'on s'est rendu
compte au travers de l'enquète c'est que
bien que les documents ont été
déclassifiés en 2013 par le ministre de
la défense de l'époque jean yves le
drian en groupe ils ont très peu circulé
en fait ils ont pas été rendu
on va dire exploitable par par des
chercheurs
et puis une deuxième barrière quand on a
déjà dit sont extrêmement techniques
donc on va des tables des graphiques ce
genre de choses et donc si on n'a pas un
peu les moyens de lire et de recouper
d'extraire tout s'est donné ça devient
extrêmement compliqué spécialiste du
nucléaire militaire
des experts tels que vous ça se compte
sur les doigts d'une main en france est
très difficile d'avoir une expertise
comme celles que vous avez je pense que
ce soit se comptent sur les doigts d'une
main et généralement cette expertise
elle est bien sûr au sein des
institutions gouvernementales et donc
c'est très difficile pour quelqu'un au
sein des institutions gouvernementales
normalement de faire une expertise
indépendante sur ces questions là quoi
le pouvoir publier là dessus donc pour
moi c'est le fait d'avoir cette
connaissance technique mais aussi
d'autres universitaires notamment aux
états unis qui a pu permettre ce projet
je pense d'aboutir si vous venez nous
rejoindre sur figaro live nous sommes
diffusés en direct sur lefigaro.fr et
sur la chaîne youtube figaro live vous
pouvez nous poser vos questions et nous
livrer vos commentaires concernant ce
sujet que nous traitons aujourd'hui en
direct avec sébastien philippe qui est
expert en nucléaire militaire
à savoir les essais nucléaires en
polynésie qui ont eu lieu pendant 30
entre 1966 et 1996
ceci l'a fait l'actualité puisque le
chef de l'état emmanuel macron est en ce
moment en polynésie il fait une visite
présidentielle on le voit sur ces images
qui ont été tournées et livré il ya
quelques heures ils étaient arrivés aux
îles marquises aujourd'hui il sera
demain je crois de retour à papeete où
il devrait livrer un discours qui
normalement devrait faire référence à
ses essais nucléaires en tout cas les
polynésiens sont en attente un certain
nombre d'annoncés on le verra sébastien
philippe ses essais nucléaires dont on
disait qu'ils avaient eu un impact sur
la santé des populations locales
combien de personnes pourraient être
potentiellement victimes de ces essais
nucléaires qui ont eu lieu pendant 30
ans
s'attendent à être peut-être indemnisées
par l'état français alors
le nombre de personnes va vraiment
dépendre aujourd'hui au travers de la
loi sur l inca l'exposition ces
personnes ont reçu ce qui a été assez
exceptionnelle on va dire est incroyable
à travers notre enquête c'est qu'on
s'est rendu compte que les chiffres qui
sont utilisés aujourd'hui pour les
décisions de conversation 1 on peut être
sous-estimée par les facteurs de 2 à 10
avec est en réalité en réévaluant cet
impact mais aussi en reconstruction
reconstruisant la la trajectoire de
certains nuages radioactifs au-dessus de
la polynésie on s'est rendu compte que
par plus de 90% de la population à
l'époque plus de cent dix mille
personnes ont pu être impacté
et si le chiffre est avancé de 110 mille
personnes qui potentiellement été
touchées par par ses retombées de nuage
radioactif et qui ont pu être contaminés
en ingérant des aliments qui parlait
pluie tombée suite à ces à ses essais
atomiques ont été contaminé les eaux de
pluie aussi vous en parlez dans votre
livre
puisqu'une bonne partie de la population
à cette époque là buvez de l'eau via
l'eau des pluies qui était chargée donc
en atom en tout cas contaminés
emmanuel macron je le disais sébastien
philippe et est très attendue donc c'est
sur cette question du nucléaire
à quel type d'annoncé faut-il s'attendre
est ce que c'est une reconnaissance de
l'état français voire des excuses de la
france qui pourrait être fait non je
pense qu'on verra ça demain
pendant son discours mais pour l'instant
et semble qu'il n'y aura pas d' excuses
de la france aujourd'hui
mais un effort de
faire plus de pas en avant vers la
reconnaissance des victimes donc on sait
pas exactement encore quelle forme ça va
prendre
évidemment on attend son intervention
publique demain au chef de l'état pour
savoir exactement de quoi il en retourne
mais vous le dit hein pour l'instant pas
d'excusés effectivement geneviève
darrieussecq ministre délégué auprès de
la ministre des armées chargées de la
mémoire et des anciens combattants a
écarté un début juillet l'hypothèse
d'une demande de pardon de la france est
ce qu'aujourd'hui malgré tout l'état
français reconnaît un lien entre les
essais nucléaires et les problèmes de
santé au sein de la population
polynésienne
oui alors on a une loi depuis 2010 la
loi morin sur ces questions là où on
reconnaît une présentation causalité
entre les gens qui étaient présents
pendant les essais nucléaires notamment
aériens où il y avait des retombées sur
sur sur les populations locales
on reconnaît une présomption de
causalité quand ils développent un
certain type de cancer et qu'ils étaient
présents à ce moment là encore une fois
il y avait qu un une petite
un petit bémol c'est à dire qu'on donne
aussi au comité d'indemnisation le droit
à de renverser cette présomption et de
refuser l'indemnisation si on considère
que les personnes n'ont pas été exposés
à ces on sait le nombre de maladies qui
sont associés on va dire qu'ils peuvent
être reconnus comme comme nous des
cancers en particulier
je crois qu'il ya une liste d'une
vingtaine de maladie c'est
potentiellement peuvent être issus de
déchets nucléaires en tout cas de
contamination par le nucléaire
peut-être que raphaël lazreg qui est en
régie paix de montrer la liste de ces
voix-là cancer du sein cancer de la
thyroïde
ça fait quand même un une liste assez
longue toutes ces maladies sont été
retrouvé en polynésie vous avez eu des
des études qui montrait que une maladie
en particulier parmi toutes celles qui
sont terminées énuméré sont plus
prégnante sur place alors il ya eu des
études scientifiques qui ont été faits
par certains chercheurs de l'ircem
notamment sur les cancers de la thyroïde
et aussi au travers de notre enquête on
a dix klose a pu révéler des notes qui
ont circulé qui font état de kloster de
cancer tu aurais dit thyroïdiens pendant
si vous voyez dans lesquels se concentre
un nombre anormal de malades c'est ça la
même maladie il faut savoir que la
thyroïde c'est un des organes et plus
radiosensibles donc il fixe l'iodé
radioactif qui est directement libéré
dans ces explosions nucléaires sur le
chat youtube figaro live jonathan g
merci d'être en direct avec nous dans
vos commentaires vous demandez à
sébastien philipps jusqu'où
géographiquement ces essais ont eu un
impact est ce qu on le sait ça ah oui
parce que quand j'ai fait la
modélisation des essais ont fait josé
modélisés
sur plusieurs semaines et donc en règle
générale ils partent donc des atolls de
mururoa et fangataufa à il passe au
dessus de la polynésie en partie puis se
dirigent vers l'amérique du sud
on voit une des ces modélisations en
tout cas c'est celle qui a fait beaucoup
parler elle concerne un essai qui on y
reviendra sur cet essai particulièrement
on expliquera à ceux qui nous regardent
ce qui s'est passé exactement mais on
voit ce nuage qui se dirige vers la
pauline et d'enfants en tout cas l'île
de tahiti symbolisée par ce petit 8
blanc vers lequel se dirige le nuage
rouge donc voilà deux murs euros à les
particules chargées en atomes sont allés
directement sur tahiti
et donc ça c'est un essai parmi les 193
en tout cas parmi les essais
atmosphériques qui impacte et une partie
de la polynésie
il ya eu 46 alors celui là c'est celui
qui a impacté le plus de monde puisque
comme on a vu sur la vidéo il est parti
d'un numéro un il est directement allé
sur tahiti en ligne droite
il faut savoir qu'à l'époque les
populations n'ont pas été prévenus et
endosse liste ce qui se passait 1974
c'est la dernière année des essais
atmosphériques
c'est la dernière année avec cet essai
inquiets d'être du 17 juillet celui dont
on vient voir la modélisation là c'est
une vidéo qui illustre ce à quoi
ressemble à un
un essai atomique atmosphérique
c'est-à-dire dans l'air après 74 on est
sur des essais
souterrains c'est ça il n'y a plus ce
phénomène de champignons non non non on
est on
on passe à des essais souterrains parce
que l'opinion mondiale notamment et puis
française aussi à ce moment là se rend
compte qu'il ya des effets des retombées
sur les populations et ça devient de
moins en moins acceptable
donc on passe un régime ont fait des
explosions souterraines
comment ça se passe pour un explosion de
cette ampleur là en souterrain soutien à
l'art on creuse
en creusant ford et puis on fait de la
merde dans les sols dans le sol de la
tle dans le sol de la table ou alors
sous le lagon parce que le lagon n'ya
que 40 mètres de profondeur et on va le
camp pendant creuser un puits 1 900
mètres de profondeur près d'un kilomètre
de là c'est ça et faire exploser logique
jeu complet au fond c'est la même chose
que ce qu'on fait exploser dans l'air
mais on fait en souterrain
est ce que le blessé dont on a vu tout à
l'heure la modélisation l'essai centaure
sur lequel on reviendra en détail tout à
l'heure est-ce que c'est lui qui marque
la fin c'est parce qu'il ya eu on le
verra une erreur d'orientation du nuage
dont on pensait qu'ils allaient partir
en pleine mer mais en fait il s'est
dirigé vers tahiti qui a marqué la fin
des essais atmosphériques
alors les essais atmosphériques étaient
déjà prévues dès le début de la campagne
président giscard d'estaing l'époque
nous dit que ce sera la dernière en
atmosphère inc qui est qu'ensuite on
passera en souterrain et que mais il
fallait absolument faire celle-là
du coup il ya un calendrier que les
documents déclassifiés d'ailleurs
décrivent comme extrêmement tendue et
chargé qui poussent là le système de
sécurité de sûreté a ses limites et
on voit le résultat quoi ça il ya eu un
gros raté cette analyse ces essais
nucléaires français en polynésie en fait
ils ont suivi je crois des essais qui
avait d'abord été réalisé sous la
présidence du général de gaulle en
algérie et justement on a un internaute
sur le sur le chat youtube du figaro qui
demande ya saab
merci pour votre question qu'en est il
des essais nucléaires en algérie combien
y en at il eu ou ont-ils été effectués
et combien y at il une victime pour et
on les considérait comme crimes de
guerre alors c'est pas le sujet qui nous
concerne aujourd'hui mais ça fait partie
des essais nucléaires menés par la
france
ils ont été faits avant les essais
nucléaires en polynésie est ce que vous
pouvez éclairé il ya sap de sur ces
questions il y en a eu dix sept essais à
4 dans l'atmosphère et 13 en souterrain
et on a beaucoup d'informations sur ces
essais là mais il ya eu et a encore
aujourd'hui 0 modélisation étude
d'impact on va dire plus indépendante
sur les populations locales
mais on sait que par exemple le nuage la
première bombe atomique française s'est
déplacé sur tout le nord de l'afrique y
arriver jusqu'au sud de l'europe aussi
sur les causes de la chaise oui sur le
site de la france a forcément été
impactés oui voilà manière on va dire
relative
voilà on fera partie d'une analyse d'une
enquête que vous pourriez mené là c'est
peut-être
vous dites dans votre dans votre enquête
que je cite la question de l'ampleur et
de l'intensité de l'impact radiologique
est toujours à trancher
pour quelle raison parce qu'on n'a pas
en bien qu'on ait eu accès à deux mille
pages de documents on n'a pas eu accès à
tous il ya des documents qui sont
toujours pas déclassifiés à il ya eu 46
essais aériens de 66 74
pour certains on a des documents qui
vont raconter l'impact sur
l'environnement et l'impact sur les
populations pour d'autres on n'a rien ou
parfois un petit bout ou parfois les
documents et est pas complètement
déclassifiés donc on peut toujours pas
aujourd'hui faire la somme de tout ce
qui s'est passé à madère et 7,7
cette déclassification est ce qu'elle
est à venir où elle restera
verrouilleront de toute façon toujours
certains certains documents certains
documents à seront verrouillées
mais je pense que s'il ya une des
avancées qui sera potentiellement lancé
demain ça sera sur la question des
documents et la déclassification plus de
complications pourraient être déclassées
alors pour moi je pense que tous les
documents qui sont liées aux essais
atmosphériques et qui sont va dire
connexes à ce qu'on a déjà vue doivent
être dictée claire déclassifiés il a pas
extrêmement peu d'informations pour les
fait rentrer dans ces documents
ah et puis je pense qu'il serait
intéressant notamment pour les
polynésiens l'historien c'est aussi
avoir accès aux documents plus politique
est prise de décision à l'elysée
dans les ministères alors deux choses
aujourd'hui on a très peu accès à ces
documents là vous avez eu vos accès à
des documents dont vous n'avez pas pu
révéler le contenu donc tous les
documents qu'on a révélé ils étaient
déjà déclassifiés à on sait qu'il ya des
travaux universitaires qui sont en cours
certains cherchant certaines archives et
donc sûrement on en apprendra plus dans
les années qui viennent
parmi les points qui interpelle en
lisant votre enquête c'est l'opacité qui
entoure les mesures de contamination
vous dites que l'étude des archives
déclassifiées révèle d'importantes
commissions dans les calculs du
commissariat à l'énergie atomique
vous évoquez également les mesures
insuffisantes de contamination des
denrées alimentaires et de l'eau potable
à l'époque comment elle s'explique c
ommission à cette époque là on imagine
que l'armée était déjà suffisamment
équipé pour faire toutes les aides d
analyser les études nécessaires
on est équipé mais c'est pas forcément
la priorité on considère finalement
quand on peut et on sait qu'on va
exposer les populations parce que c'est
impossible de pas exposées les
populations ex ssm océanique en faites
quoi qu'il arrive en les exposant donc
on a plutôt un système qui est en place
pour gérer les accidents mais j'ai lu
récemment une note encore du ceva de
qui explique que le système était mis en
place était pas mis en place pour
calculer de façon précise les deux
opérations
donc c'était quelque chose qui ne les
intéressait pas mais de façon consciente
parce qu'on savait que les impacts
aigles y en aurait mais ce n'était pas
la priorité
parce qu'ils étaient trop peu nombreux
on peut rappeler que ce sont des atolls
des archipels avec une population de
faible importance on va dire même si ce
sont des gens
est ce que est ce que c'est ce voilà
est-ce que c'est us étant que ça ne se
voit pas finalement ça ne se sait pas
oui voilà donc il ya cet aspect qui est
déjà à l'époque en 66 donc comme on à
dire ya eu ces essais en algérie qui
sont déjà en sous terrain à la fin on
revient un des essais atmosphériques
alors que les états-unis la russie en
bretagne ont décidé d'arrêter
complètement les essais atmosphériques
la france décide de les reprendre il ya
une grosse pression alors que la
tendance était plutôt à fabrice ferat
parce que on voulait absolument faire
des explosions méga tonique les plus
grosses en gros possibles et imaginables
c'est essentiellement politique
et c'était voilà une décision va dire à
l'époque la protection de la nation quoi
on voulait faire du théâtre d'accord je
pense que c'est ça la réponse
ouais ouais c'est parce que il ya toute
une discussion oui ce serait trop
compliqué de faire des essais
souterrains en polynésie à l'époque
sauf qu'à partir de 75 dont les commencé
là il ya aucun problème puisque ça va
durer jusqu'en 96 et au final peu près
on s'est rendu compte qu'on a même des
meilleurs parfois des meilleurs
résultats de mesures quand on fait
tourner en souterrain s'est on n'est pas
dépendant de la météo ce genre de choses
alors c'est vrai que quand on voit une
explosion atomique atmosphérique
aérienne c'est excessivement
impressionnant on voit ce champignon que
l'on connaît tous qu'on identifie
parfaitement où vous à diffuser déjà un
certain nombre d'image on envoie une
encore maintenant les essais souterrains
vous dites que apporte parfois des
mesures plus précises ou des résultats
plus probants
malgré tout on peut pas considérer que
les essais souterrains sont inoffensifs
les impacts sur les zones où les essais
ont eu lieu c'était quoi
oui alors là bas il ya eu des impacts on
va dire plus d'abord géomécanique six
ans
la fracture fracturent la roche ont il
ya eu il ya eu des effondrements des
parois des récifs des atolls dans
lesquels on a fait des essais il ya eu d
des techniciens du commissaire à
l'énergie atomique qui ont été blessées
d'ailleurs il ya eu des vagues de
tsunami qui ont suivi certains essais
qui sont passés par dessus qui ont
balayé certaines personnes qui étaient
si on te croit sur des bateaux bijou
d'apple nom et sur la tasse sur l'atoll
en lui-même - et donc après ça ils ont
construit des plateformes sur place et à
chaque fois qu'il vient et c'est tout le
monde veuille monter sur les plateformes
mais en gros c'était vraiment plus voilà
la détruire enfin on détruit on abîme la
structure de la colle ça on s'est rendu
compte bien sûr assez rapidement de ce
qui se passe et si oui donc ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui les atolls en tout cas
celui de mauro a par exemple dont on
parlait tout à l'heure et est fragilisée
il pourrait disparaître même s'enfoncer
dans les eaux alors je pense que on va
plutôt voir le réchauffement climatique
qui va faire monter des eaux s'est fait
submerger l'automne avant que la tôle
s'effondre il ya certaines parties de la
tôle qui sont vraiment fragilisé
notamment une qui fait face à un autre
atolls qui est celui de tu rien qui est
le plus proche
habiter et où d'ailleurs les habitants
dans les essais aériens ont vraiment été
exposées de manière importante et ces
gens là en fait ben si une partie de la
teinte dans les pires scénarios on va
dire enveloppe de ce qui pourrait se
passer il pourrait avoir une mini vague
tsunami qui rêverait et pourrait balayer
aussi leur île et donc on a installé un
système de surveillance sismique et qui
essayent de mesurer les déplacements et
de près les conditions pratiquement à
peu près dans votre enquête vous avez
donc évaluer l'impact de ces essais à la
hausse c'est à dire que par rapport à ce
que l'armée avait donné comme
information à l'origine devait
finalement on est loin du compte
on est sur des chiffres fois deux fois
deux ennemis x 3 en particulier sur les
enfants
est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner des
précisions supplémentaires par rapport
aux chiffres que vous avez pu récupérer
vous aux études et vos recherches que
vous avez fait à partir des données
d'origine
mais alors donc on a ce qui était
intéressant qu'on s'est rendu compte
plus on va dire au milieu à peu près 2
de l'enquète c'était que les chiffres
officiels qui ont été produits pour la
dernière fois il ya 15 ans en 2006 avait
été fait à partir de l'étude de
documents qu'ils étaient maintenant
déclassifiés donc on avait les la
première fois on avait les calculs pas
les explications est vraiment précises
sur comment il avait été fait mais en
grande partie plus les données sources
et on a pu vérifier ces calculs pour la
première fois on s'est rendu compte
qu'il y avait eu des erreurs qui avaient
des données qu'ils n'avaient pas été
prises en compte et que parfois on
prenait des valeurs qui étaient moins
élevés d'un côté comme de l'autre
par exemple puisse pas une mesure de
contamination d'eau de pluie on en a
deux et on va pas prendre celle qui est
la plus élevée on va prendre celle qui
est la moins élevée par exemple donc
c'est en faisant ce travail de fourmi et
de reconstruction qu'on a pu arriver à
ces différences qui était extrêmement
enfin moi qui vont vraiment surprise
survient vous mettez en parallèle on va
dire les doses reçues par certains
enfants en particulier que vous comparez
avec la l'explosion de la centrale
nucléaire de tchernobyl dans les années
on est sur des rapports équivalent grave
donc grave et notamment sur les atolls
qui sont les plus proches donc que ce
soit l'archipel des gambier ou la tôle
de turian j'ai déjà mentionné
on a laissé des enfants boire de l'eau
contaminée aux produits de fission
sachant sachant dans quel site et un
élevé de l'eau et combien il avait
ingéré pas nettoyer les citernes et on
les a laissés faire et ainsi aujourd'hui
une personne sur ces atolls un cancer de
la thyroïde par exemple et qui est que
vous prenez en compte l'historique de
des impacts des essais il est clair et
net que que claque il ya vraiment un
lien de cause à effet a un lien vraiment
fort sur l'augmentation du risque
on va le voir peut-être que vous avez
via le média d'investigation avec lequel
vous avez fait cette enquête
il y a voilà une animation avec des
informations voilà sur un enfant de un
deux ans l'exposition la contamination
total est-ce qu'on peut décoder alors si
on peut faire une image arrêtée sur
cette animation et ses informations
raphaël va nous redonner voilà qu'est ce
qu'on peut à on l'a pas voilà merci
beaucoup rappellent donc si vous pouvez
juste nous déco 17
oui c'est la glace et on va dire c'est
la dose reçue par un enfant de deux ans
ça c'est à tahiti donc suite à l'essai
centaure de 1974 dont on a mis le nuage
tout à l'heure a donc l'enfant et r&d au
passage
enfin en gros est exposée au passage du
nuage a au passage du nuage il ya aussi
des fortes pluies et donc il ya un dépôt
radioactif au sol et donc vous avez une
irradiation l'enfant par en gros parce
qu'il est retombé au sol et puis ensuite
à la consommation d'eau contaminée
la consommation d'aliments contaminés
mais aussi la respiration au moment du
passage du nuage de particules
radioactives
vous faites la somme de tout simple donc
là c'est un des enfants qu'il était
peut-être le moins contaminés on a pas
on n'a pas mis les plus gros chiffres ça
monte beaucoup plus haut que ça mais
c'est au dessus aujourd'hui de la limite
à laquelle
[Musique]
on a le droit à une indemnisation si on
a si on vient à développer un des
cancers de la liste
dan bensimon nous demande sûr sur
youtube merci pour sa question quid de
l'impact des essais nucléaires sur les
soldats de l'armée française
effectivement on n'a pas encore parlé
des vétérans on a parlé des populations
polynésiennes et vétérans aussi ont été
impactés par csl ah oui absolument
oui donc les par les vétérans surtout
encore une fois pendant les essais
aériens
vous avez des bateaux qui sont dont le
but est de suivre le nuage donc dans les
documents qu'on a pu voir on voit les
cartes marines des bateaux qui traverse
la retombée radioactive qui font des
mesures les alertes à bord le besoin de
nettoyer les bateaux les atolls de
mururoa et fangataufa leur lagon fait
l'essai peuvent être fortement
contaminée juste après donc on doit
attendre un certain temps pour que les
bateaux puissent venir se remettre à
quai retravaillé et sur ces bateaux je
vais vous donner un exemple très concret
sur un bateau de la marine il faut faire
de l'eau douce pour pouvoir boire et
donc pour faire de l'eau douce on prend
de l'eau salée et on l'a des salles dont
la fille est chauffée et donc il ya des
gens leur métier c'était vérifié les
appareils qui faisait de l'eau douce à
bord et à ses appareils de tous était
fortement contaminée avec des particules
fines radioactives et ils ont pu être
exposés à des doses importantes aussi
oui on reviendra sur le fait que vous
êtes allé à la rencontre 1-2 polynésiens
victimes et puis deux vétérans de
l'armée française qui ont
potentiellement et probablement été
contaminés et malades des suites de ces
essais alors parmi ces essais
atmosphériques dont on parle en il y en
a un qui a été réalisé et qui ont été
réalisés entre 66 et 74 mais il y en a
un qui vous a particulièrement intéressé
on a déjà évoqué c'est l'essai centaure
réalisé donc je le disais le 17 juillet
1974 à mururoa
c'est le 41e essais nucléaires
atmosphériques dans le pacifique
et cet essai a été un fiasco si on peut
dire ça comme ça alors en collaboration
avec disclose vous avez fait une
modélisation qu'on découvre à l'image on
en a vu un petit bout tout à l'heure
peut-être vous pouvez sébastien philippe
nous commenter exactement et nous
expliquer ce qui s'est passé pourquoi
cet essai
a échoué voilà ce nuage rouge
à l'origine je crois qu'il y avait déjà
une altitude de nuages qui était attendu
par l'armée mais qui n'a pas atteint son
objectif et puis après il ya des
histoires de vent oui voilà donc
généralement on s'attend à ce que le
nuage partent vers l'est c'est bien dans
la direction complètement opposée
et ce jour là pour on sait toujours pas
exactement pourquoi parce que ses
calculs il aurait dû être fait et puis
on avait des données météo à des heures
très proche du tir mais le tir a été
validé et le nuage est tout de suite
parti vers l'ouest vers tahiti et il
atteint tahiti en combien de temps on
voit il ya un décompte ces deux jours
donc il y avait le temps peut-être
d'évacuer les populations les protégez
vous penser alors des évacués
pas forcément mais en tout cas de les
protéger c'est à dire main de dieu hand
elles ne l'ont pas et pc chez eux non
rappel vous mettez dans le livre et puis
aussi de gérer en fait la contamination
des aliments et donc faire en sorte que
les gens ne consomment pas à certaines
choses dans sa a pas du tout été fait
alors dans un des passages du livre on
voit un échange dans les documents que
vous avez pu consulter qui ont été
déclassifiés
qui met en avant un propos de militaires
sûr on va minimiser ce qui s'est passé
pour ne pas affoler les populations
le fait de ne pas informer tahiti et les
populations à tahiti que le nuage
arrivée chez eux
c'était une volonté délibérée de l'armée
donc c'était un manque de temps non je
pense que la volonté délibérée de ne pas
informer les populations en 1974 oui je
pense que comme je disais en 1974
c'était la dernière année des essais
atmosphériques
il y avait eu un des ministres du
gouvernement du président giscard
d'estaing qui avait démissionné juste
avant la reprise et c'est parce qu'il
était totalement contre donc il y avait
un climat politique aussi qui était à
l'époque on n'a toujours pas accès à ces
archives là donc on n'a pas la réponse
mais je pense que il ya eu ce fiasco on
sait que l'amiral qui était en charge de
la direction des essais a été mis à pied
en quelques jours il est rentré à paris
alors qu'il devait y avoir un tir
qu'elle un autre tir quelques jours
après donc on se rend compte que oui il
ya eu des répercussions c'est une
décision interne à l'armée c'est à dire
que ils ont une conscience et
connaissance du désastre que ça pu être
mais d'un point de vue public et polis
et
officielle sana pas transparaître non
non non non non il ya eu un secret
complet sur sur cet épisode là est
d'ailleurs en fait on commence à
apprendre un petit peu ce qui s'est
passé pour la première fois dans les
années 97 98 après la fermeture du
centre d'expérience puisque on sait
pourquoi l'armée malgré la connaissance
qu'ils avaient d'une d'un changement du
vent qui n'en qu'il n'emmènerait pas le
ce nuage vers l'est mais plutôt
complètement sur l'ouest et en
l'occurrence sur la capitale de la
polynésie pourquoi le tir n'a pas été
annulée même la dernière minute alors ce
qui même incroyable c'est que le tir en
fait deux
montrer les dernières simulations
montrent que le nuage partait
normalement vers le nord je crois que
ces douze heures avant au dessus du nil
qui habitait mais avec peu d'habitants
et on a considéré que l'impact serait a
pas très important et donc on a validé
le tir sachant que ça allait déjà
impacté veut dire une centaine de
personnes mais la voilà gros problème
peut-être un gros problème de données
météo la dernière minute je ne sais pas
mais on sait que les expérimentateurs
ont vu tout de suite le nuage s'est levé
et partie assez haut déjà pas assez haut
bien que un tout petit peu un peu plus
hauts claquent la hauteur de sécurité
donc normalement il y aurait dû avoir
des calculs avec la météo du moment
à cette hauteur de sécurité donc il ya
eu un rôle énorme dans votre bureau et
lisa sion on voit que le nuage passe au
dessus d'eux
de tahiti mais il va pas s'arrêter
au-dessus d'haïti il continue sa
progression il passe ou après il passe
il fait le tour de la terre alors
généralement oui les nuages quand ils
partent ils font le tour de latin à peu
près trois semaines donc et on leur
mesure en leur mesure encore une fois au
dessus de la polynésie dont deux a320
potentiel de contamination s'atténue au
fur et à mesure du temps où il avait
contaminé d'autres espaces peuple et
dans la suite de sa trajectoire
alors pour cette c'est là en particulier
je me suis arrêté après plusieurs jours
on va dire je page est parfait la
totalité des calculs mais sur d'autres
et c'est que gérard modélisé sur trois
semaines et on va dire les essais plus
classique
oui vous avez vous mesuré d'une hausse
de la radioactivité en amérique du sud
parfois importantes surtout en amérique
du sud et puis après partout dans
l'hémisphère sud à des degrés beaucoup
moindre mais mais qui sont quand même
qu'ils sont mesurables quoi il ayant en
fait ces données sont dans des tables
dans les documents déclassifiés qu'on a
pu voir donc j'ai pu comparer les
modélisations aux données mesurées
je travaillerai sûrement à plus de
publications sur sur ce sujet là vous
parlez pourtant de transparence
revendiquée par le ministère de la
défense est là elle a ses limites cette
transparence en définitive est là elle a
eu ses limites oui oui historiquement je
crois que c'est vraiment un sujet qui
est difficile de gérer pendant une
semaine la défense pour le commissaire à
l'énergie atomique alors historiquement
donc il ya eu les mensonges du débat du
début on sait on a caché aux populations
et s'éteint mais depuis 96 maintenant on
a arrêté tout ça on est même signataire
du traité d'interdiction des essais
nucléaires donc on est vraiment on est
vraiment passé à autre chose
complètement mais je crois qu'il ya
toujours ce problème de voile à de dire
qu'on a une responsabilité qu'on n'a pas
fait ce qu'il fallait faire qu'on n'a
pas protégé les populations c'est très
difficile et aussi au delà de ça on fait
ça une répercussion légales et
financières
parce qu'aujourd'hui on indemnise
certaines certaines victimes à me dire
sous un régime de solidarité nationale
mais on part du principe que la france a
pas de responsabilité dans ce qui s'est
passé toujours légalement et si on
reconnaissait 7,7 cette responsabilité
savourer à une plus large indemnisation
notamment potentiellement pour les
familles vous disiez tout à l'heure des
documents clés justement importants
demeurent encore secret défense
quels sont les arguments avancés par le
ministère de la défense pour justifier
le refus de déclassifier une partie de
ses archives clé on pense évidemment aux
intérêts nationaux
mais ce sont comme vous lis des archives
clé c'est à dire qu'elles permettraient
de vraiment ouvrir totalement les vannes
à une transparence absolue qu'est ce qui
fait que ça bloque alors qu'on en sait
déjà beaucoup à au point où on en est où
pourrait aller au delà
alors il ya on va dire il ya une partie
des archives bien sûr on ne demande pas
les plans des armes qui ont été testées
bien sûr ça ça a secret mais pour tout
le reste tous les toutes les mesures qui
ont été faites c'est quand même assez
incroyable et j'avais une anecdote que
je racontais mon co auteur du livre
toxic thomas statue sur 10 m pour quand
je me suis fait opérer des dents de
sagesse
je suis allée à l'hôpital militaire et
sous anesthésie générale on les a tout
enlevé d'un seul coup j'ai pas attendu
qu'on les arrachent une paru donc là on
serait en un peu dans cette situation on
pourrait finalement on a un président
qui est d'une génération qui n'est pas
impliqué dans ces essais dont on va dire
dans cette cette période de guerre
froide
à l'époque j'ai d'ailleurs à la
déclassification de certains équipements
et du président de la république
voilà certains des classifications donc
on pourrait s'attendre au fait qu'ils
pourraient dire ça serait c'est le
moment en fait de passer de tourner la
page de d'avoir parce qu'on en reste là
c'est une réservation elles n'ont pas
enfin les autorités françaises elles
n'ont pas encore tout dit sur ce qui
s'est passé à l'époque
non non non on n'a pas il ya encore
quelques il ya encore plusieurs zones
d'ombré qui pourrait être à ce point
alors je pense pas qu'ils aient quelque
chose d'extrêmement incroyable important
on va peut-être trouvé encore certains
documents qui vont montrer qu'il ya eu
des impacts sur certaines usines des
populations qui n'ont pas été
mis au courant qu'ils ont consommé des
aliments contaminés ce genre de choses
mais je ne m'attends pas à ce qui est
personnellement on pourrait se dire vous
avez peut-être une petite idée sur la
question
alors il ment il ya certains essais pour
lequel il manque tous les documents et
on sait qu'il ya eu par exemple d'autres
tombés sur l'île de tahiti en 1966 ce
qui pourrait être mais qu'est-ce qui
serait pas non plus de de l'ordre de
satc cinq ans que j'ai re modélisés mais
il ya je peux pas répondre à toutes ces
questions et parfois c'est parfois c'est
peut-être simplement d'un point de vue
administratif on est ce qu on les as qui
sont quelque part est ce qu'on peut les
retrouver
pendant ces deux années qui ont
nécessité
la publication de cette enquête avec
thomas status vous vous avez été
empêchés d'une certaine façon ralentie
dans votre enquête par une pression
quelconque re du ministère de la défense
de lamballe anciens qui n'aimerait pas
n'aime pas qu'on ait divulgué ce type
d'information vous avez vous avez été
libre de vos actions alors on a été oui
oui on a été libre de nos sections on a
fait attention à ce qu'on faisait bien
ce qu'on faisait et la façon dans son
communiqué s'exportant aujourd'hui mais
oui on a un on n'a pas du tout non non
ça c'est vraiment très bien déroulée et
même de manière assez surprenante
à quand on a donc le livre sorti en mars
on a envoyé les questions d'assurance et
un à des fins en décembre un petit peu
avant noël et
donc là il est au courant de ce qui
allait se passer et c'est mais ça a été
non on n'a pas été entravée sur sur
cette enquête
aujourd'hui on s'interroge les îles et
territoires contaminés pendant pendant
30 ans est ce que ils ont été
décontaminées d'abord à l'époque il ya
des systèmes
physique pour les décontaminer où est-ce
qu'ils ne l'ont pas été et puis est-ce
que la pollution elle est encore
mesurables aujourd'hui alors la
pollution elle est mesurable au genre du
vent tahiti à faire un beau voyage de
noces par exemple on peut être contaminé
sur place par une réactivité
alors il ya une radioactivité résiduelle
bien sûr mais à des taux extrêmement
faibles il faut creuser le sol
certainement elle et elle est très
certainement mesurables encore
aujourd'hui on pourrait d'ailleurs
cartographier ça serait une étape
potentiellement aujourd'hui ce serait
leur cartographie de manière
indépendante
la contamination des sols de toute la
polynésie mais qui sont pas contaminés à
des degrés vraiment dangereux pour la
population jeune est prévu que ce soit
fait ça pas du tout non mais ça n'a
jamais été fait et ça serait extrêmement
intéressant de t'avoir on peut savoir
que c'est à des taux très bas
ça a été fait pendant ça a été fait oui
ça a été fait et pillé en fait on
connaît la date d essais et on sait
qu'il ya une décroissance radioactive de
ces éléments donc avec le temps la
radioactivité diminue et on sait à peu
près les éléments qui viennent qui sont
retombés donc on peut on peut faire un
calcul on va dire de simples pour savoir
que oui c'est descendu très bas
aujourd'hui on peut s'interroger comment
sont faits les essais nucléaires on sait
que la france a une capacité nucléaire
qui n'est pas négligeable
ils les font comment désormais les
essais pour vérifier que le matériel
fonctionne bien
alors on fait plus de décès à grande
échelle 1 on a des capacités de calculs
de simulation a qui font tourner donc
résoudre des équations ce genre de
choses et qui utilise les données des
essais qu'on a fait donc en polynésie
oui ils sont toujours valables qui sont
toujours malades à qu'il faut re
exploiter et puis on fait encore comme
comme dans dix ans on fait des essais
froide on va tester certaines parties de
l'arme nucléaire l'un pelouse qui va
faire imploser la matière fissible de
plutonium par exemple tout ça on peut le
tester sans faire une explosion
nucléaire
ça c'est la france on va dire il ya
peut-être les américains fonctionne un
peu comme nous également
mais qu'en est il de la corée du nord
par exemple un certain nombre
d'internautes nous demande comment font
comme ans ont effectué les essais
nucléaires par exemple en corée du nord
est ce qu on a une idée de s'ils font
des essais atmosphériques souterrain
alors passez pas atmosphérique mais
souterrains et les en compte de
plusieurs essais plusieurs essais
soutenir leur territoire sur leur
territoire et le plus récent en 2018
2019 je n'ai pas de bêtises qui était
une exclusion d'ailleurs extrêmement
forte
oui qui était mesurée avec les appareils
antisismiques
oui mais oui et de toute les de tous les
pays de l'est au tour et puis voilà
partout on a on a aujourd'hui donc ce
traité d'interdiction des essais
nucléaires qui est en place mais qui et
qui fait pas encore force de loi
complète parce qu'il manque certaines
ratification de pays clés notamment les
etats-unis la russie l'iran etc
mais on a quand même accès à tout un
réseau de mesure tout autour de la terre
qui va mesurer des explosions dans
l'atmosphère sous l'eau et on va dire
les les ondes sismiques et donc on a une
voix là on a constamment
est-ce que la surveillance du ciel est
ce qu'on peut savoir si des essais
atmosphériques nucléaires sont menées
par certains pays il y en a non il y en
a plus de sous non ça on le saurait
aujourd'hui on serait presque presque
instantanément les principaux atolls de
mururoa et puis fanga toffin que vous
avez cités sur lesquels ont lieu la
majeure partie de ces essais
atmosphériques et souterrains est-ce
qu'ils sont accessibles au public
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'on moi journaliste
je peux aller faire un visite des lieux
où est ce que le public peut s'y rendre
avec son bateau non le public peut pas
du tout c'est en un cd zones qui sont
interdites
si vous êtes j'en ai peut-être demander
une accréditation pour y aller mais
c'est vraiment non non c'est
complètement fermé ses gardes et à ses
gardes et il ya une joie qui est une
compagnie via un petit régiment et
militaires sur moi
il ya encore des zones de la tonne qui
sont contaminés jeu sous le lagon enfin
dans le lagon dans les sédiments du
lagon une partie un peu au nord est de
la tle aussi où il ya eu des essais où
on a libéré beaucoup de plutonium dans
l'atmosphère et non cette contamination
on est toujours là et bien sûr il ya il
ya ces 147 et ses soutiens on a creusé
les puits et là toutes les matières
radioactives qui qu'on a laissé la leçon
là et donc en fait là toute l'histoire
de tout ce qu'on a testé la raudière là
les les déchets qui sont issus de sa
sont encore tous là ils sont en fuite
enfouie dans la roche ils sont aux
fruits dans la roche en souterrain et il
est
il pourrait ressortir et contaminer
l'eau mer en surface
alors j'imagine que deux surveillants
pour une surveillance et c'est très bon
à dire probablement non forte
probabilité que c'est pas le cas il
faudrait qu'ils aient vraiment des gros
gros mouvement de roche pour que ça
puisse sortir ça veut dire que c'est
après said he tout petit ami petit à
petit sur des milliers d'années ce genre
de choses c'est ses 143 5 ans b puis
l'aurait 147 pays sont en surveillance
permanente alors je crois pas que
individus je sais pas exactement mais je
pense pas que individuellement ils sont
en surveillance on considère qu'ils sont
plus ou moins contenue dans la roche
mais on pourrait pas aujourd'hui laisser
n'importe qui allie sur ses amis sur ces
zones-là erf aurait pour essayer de
trouver ce qui est ce qui a été fait à
l'époque alors il ya un point qu'on n'a
pas évoqué qui est la question
environnementale a évidemment de ces
essais souterrains
c'est enfouis certes dans la roche mais
au moment de l'explosion en elle même il
y avoir des dégâts considérables sur la
faune marine
à ce moment là est-ce que ça ça a été
évaluée housse indifférait totalement ce
n'était pas une question qui importe est
à l'époque alors c'était pas une
question qui importe et à l'époque
vraiment il ya eu des impacts
environnementaux forts un pour les
essais atmosphériques vous avez les plus
grosses explosions vraiment vous faire
raser la surface une partie d'atolls
m'ont brûlé tous les arabes oui on a vu
quelques images
pamiers qui sont allongés sur le sol
touché sur le sol comme s'il avait été
brûlée au napalm
quand vous avez une explosion sur le
lagon il y en a eu vous avez aussi l'eau
du lagon qui va s'élever sous la boule
de feu toute la faune et nature royer
sont tous avoir pas nominée mais bouge
et qui veut brûler oui mais oui et en
sont atteints dans les essais nucléaires
sous marin souterrain langues de chat
nom de cheval et des poissons aussi mais
bon ça c'est voilà peut-être pas
considérer la question aux questions là
sébastien philippe vous dites dans votre
livre que 233 documents déclassifiés en
2013 2013 recèle de trésors
d'information et pourtant marginalement
utilisé par les journalistes et
chercheurs
vous avez vous ajouté que ce sont des
contenus resté inconnu du grand public
jusqu'à aujourd'hui c'est une question
sur laquelle on est passé tout à l'heure
mais j'aimerais qu'on y revienne
ça peut sembler totalement incroyable et
vous l'expliquez comment cette retenue
on va dire sur le sujet les journalistes
on imagine aurait dû se jeter dessus
mais le scientifique également vous
parler d'une expertise qui est la vôtre
qui n'est pas d'un grand nombre
dans le monde mais malgré tout on
s'interroge sur le manque d'intérêt pour
ce sujet là depuis 2013 en tout cas
alors c'est ça a été donc ce que j'ai
appris aussi récemment donc en 2013 il
ya été récupéré par certains chercheurs
de l'inrs
l'inserm qui ont tous photocopier envoyé
à des collègues
voilà pour partager pour étudier ces
documents donc il ya une en parallèle de
nos travaux en fait il y avait donc
cette étude qui a commencé par se pince
le groupe de recherche qui a aussi
publié ses résultats notamment sur les
cancers de la thyroïde et donc il ya eu
ils ont pris énormément de temps pour le
faire nous ça nous a pris deux ans
certains groupes ça leur a pris huit ans
pour le faire à
mais au niveau 2 oui c'était incroyable
que des documents n'ont pas circulé ont
pas été rendus publics
vraiment je ne me l'expliqué toujours
pas en fait de retour d'un certain
nombre de scientifiques qui vous
expliquer le pourquoi de ce manque
d'intérêt on va dire je pense je sais
pas s'il ya un manga mais il y a l'un
des gros problèmes qui avait c'était
qu'il fallait trouver les bonnes
personnes pour faire ce projet il
fallait un journaliste pour faire le
travail journalistique il fallait un
scientifique pour décoder tout ça est un
scientifique qui justement vous parlez
on nous a pas mis de bâtons dans les
roues mais parce que je suis
universitaire sera une manière
indépendante jeunes en une sa ce thème
est inquiet je suis aussi associé à
série à sciences po ici à paris mais
c'est par cette indépendance qui ça nous
a permis aussi de faire ce travail
j'aimerais qu'on revienne on l'a évoqué
rapidement tout à l'heure que sur le
fait que pour les besoins de cette
enquête vous êtes allés sur place en
polynésie rencontrer des témoins sur les
lieux des faits et puis les acteurs des
essais aussi des vétérans de l'armée
si vous devez faire un panorama des des
retours qui vous ont été faits des
témoignages que vous avez reçu que vous
ont dit ces gens en fait ce sont des
gens qui sont qui sont extrêmement
difficilement c'est mon collègue thomas
statut ce qui a fait la plupart de ses
interviews en polynésie notamment à
messi sont des gens qui sont des
victimes à plein de niveaux enfin
notamment que les gens qui sont reconnus
comme victimes des essais sont les gens
qui ont déjà eu un cancer qui ont dû se
battre contre le cancer ou des membres
de familles de personnes qui sont
décédées donc il ya une charge
émotionnelle extrêmement importantes sur
ces questions là sont des gens qui
comprennent pas pourquoi ça leur arrive
est nécessairement à ils veulent un
pardon une reconnaissance qui ne
semblera peut-être pas rêver demain on
verra
ils ont besoin de cette reconnaissance
ils ont besoin qu'on les considère en
fait comme comme des êtres humains et
comme comme des citoyens est con qu'on
adresse leur voile alors leur maladie et
leur situation qui est parfois
extrêmement difficile cette situation
défi qui difficile avec elle ils sont
confrontés pour ce besoin de
reconnaissance les vétérans de l'armée
qui ont été touchée aussi par ses essais
atomiques
ces essais nucléaires est ce que vous
c'est pareil aussi c'est difficile pour
ces anciens de l'armée de faire valoir
leur oui c'est difficile parce que c'est
difficile aussi parce qu'on a fait
partie d'une institution pour laquelle
on était à l'époque aussi on devait se
tenir au secret et c'est donc on n'a pas
forcément envie de demander mais ça
prend du temps c'est parfois difficile
d'avoir accès
à son propre dossier on comprend pas
toujours les mesures qui ont été faites
sur nous que ce soit portée des petits
appareils qui mesurent la radioactivité
comprenez où certaines personnes
devaient se moucher dans un mouchoir et
on regarde essayer des particules de
plutonium qui sortait etc
des analyses médicales c'est extrêmement
compliqué pour les vétérans aussi de
faire ce chemin là à
et c'est d'ailleurs tellement c'était
tellement compliqué juste avant la mode
2010 classe une des seules personnes qui
avaient réussi à se faire indemniser à
était quelqu'un qui avait écrit le
manuel de radioprotection amoureux -
c'est à dire que c'était la personne qui
a émis les règles en place et les
mesures et qui faisait tout tous ces
calculs
à l'époque en 66 c'est parce qu'elle
connaissait tout ça qu'elle a été
capable d'être indemnisées parce que ça
va ce qui lui était arrivé en fait mais
tous les autres avaient été refusés
jusqu'à jusqu'à présent aujourd'hui
quand vous évoqué la centaine de
milliers d'individus qui potentiellement
pourrait être victimes de ces essais
nucléaires qui ont eu lieu je le
rappelais pendant trente ans entre 66 et
96 est ce qu'elles peuvent demander
toute réparation est ce qu'elles vont
pouvoir accéder à des indemnisations
vous parlez dans votre ouvrage est votre
enquête de l'opacité du civ nc ou
sylvain le comité chargé d'indemniser
les victimes qui fait du cas par cas
pour certains ça marche pour d'autres ça
marche pas est-ce que ça ça pourrait
changer est ce que les annonces que
pourrait faire le président de la
république demain pourrait transformer
la prise en charge des malades
je pense qu'il le faut de toute façon
s'il ya vraiment quelque chose qui était
qui a vraiment pas fonctionné on va dire
c'est ce système là depuis le début
pareil dans notre enquête c'était assez
incroyable parce qu'on a trouvé sur sur
le fonctionnement de cette institution
donc qui mise en place c'était la loi
morin 2010 tu 2010 à 2016
elle met en place une méthodologie
scientifique basé qui est censé disent
les données qu'elle n'a pas et donc elle
rend des décisions d'indemnisation elle
refuse 96 97 % des demandes
en utilisant des données dans telle
qu'elle n'a pas les calculs qu'elle a
jamais vérifié oui et même en outils en
utilisant des données
on va dire erronée qui sont qui doit
être utilisé différemment et pour moi en
tant que scientifique c'était incroyable
de voir ça on utilise annonce que c'est
en place alors ça ça s'est arrêté en
à partir de 2017 il ya un nouveau avant
d'utiliser une sorte de logiciel de
calcul qui a été fait par les états unis
pour indemniser les travailleurs du
nucléaire mais pas les victimes des
essais nucléaires
donc on utilise ce système là un peu une
façon la dir système d et puis ensuite
on met en place ce nouveau critère du 1
millisievert par an qui est la limite
d'exposition du public aujourd'hui en
france et qui découlent de
recommandations internationales qui
disent que c'est
potentiellement enfin c'est ok dont le
dire d'exposer la population civile
jusqu'à cette limite apparent si quand
ya pas de bénéfices personnels recevait
pas de bénéfices vous même mais qui a un
bénéfice pour la société
d'une manière générale donc c'est ce qui
s'applique par exemple pour diagnostic
médical radiothérapie ce genre de
choisir vous pouvez être exposés mais on
utilise des technologies qui sont là et
qui sont la bonne pour nous mais de
manière générale pas c'est pas forcément
le cas pour les retombées redire les
particules retombées des essais
nucléaires
donc oui voilà on va dire le système
donc pardon donc pour pour terminer 2010
est à aujourd'hui on va vérifier que les
demandeurs d'indemnisation les personnes
qui demandent ont été exposés au dessus
de ce seuil pour vérifier ça on utilise
les données produites en 2006 par le cea
a indiqué nous on a montré qu'elle ne
pouvait être qu elles ont minimisé en
tout cas parfois deux à dix fois voilà
des impacts donc quand on a revu tout ça
on s'est rendu compte que plus de cent
dix mille personnes en polynésie avait
été exposée au dessus de ce seuil
c'est presque la totalité de la
population alors pas toutes auront un
cancer faut savoir aussi que le registre
des cancers polynésie extrêmement a pas
toujours extrait a été pas très bien
tenues notamment dans les années 60 70
80 etc
c'est extrêmement difficile d'avoir des
chiffres précis on a quand même estimé
notre côté combien de cancer de coin
quand c'est à en parler et j'estime à
peu près entre 75 2021 à dix mille
personnes au moins qui aurait eu un
cancer qui pourraient être liés
aux essais nucléaires dans le cadre de
la loi morin ac c'est c'est beaucoup
plus est dix fois plus de ce qui est le
cas aujourd'hui je retiens une
soixantaine de personnes environ qui a
été pour les mises et je crois de
mémoire début nous est-ce que la
publication de votre enquête a eu un
impact vous pensez sur le choix que fait
emmanuel macron aujourd'hui d'aller
s'adresser aux polynésiens sur ce sujet
là alors je pense qu'il devait aller en
polynésie dans tous les cas mais qu'il
soit vraiment attendu cette question oui
je pense que notre enquête a vraiment eu
un impact
je vais vous citer le commentaire d'un
internaute qui s'appelle aux nuits qui
hindi et qui s'adresse à vous merci à ce
chercheur de porter cette voie qui est
la nôtre un peuple attaché à sa terre
comme un enfant à sa mère
voilà le rapport du polynésien à cette
terre merci beaucoup
on arrive à la fin de cette émission
sébastien philippe j'espère qu'on a été
complet sur sur le sujet merci de nous
avoir suivis en direct sur figaro live
merci sébastien philippe pour votre
expertise bien sûr je rappelle que vous
êtes ingénieur docteur et enseignant
chercheur à l'université de princeton
aux états unis vous êtes spécialiste du
nucléaire militaire votre livre enquête
toxiques écrit en duo avec notre
confrère le journaliste thomas statut
c'est en collaboration également avec le
média d'investigation disclose et ce
livre est publié chez puf et vous pouvez
et je vous encourage à aller regarder la
plate forme associée à cette enquête
avec ce film documentaire qui est à voir
donc sur more heroes a tiré files point
org l'adresse à sa fiche en bas de cet
écran merci encore pour vos commentaires
et vos questions à très vite sur figaro
live